I can't believe this is where we have to
start today but this is where we have to
start today Donald Trump is now tweeting
fake pictures of his own Justice
Department officials behind bars for
treason Donald Trump retweeting a tweet
originally posted by an account called
the Trump train Trump retweeted the
image the image is our television and
YouTube audiences shows not just Rod
Rosenstein behind bars but it shows
Barack Obama and Bill Clinton behind
bars Eric Holder is there I see Hillary
Clinton James Comey the President of the
United States is tweeting fake pictures
of former presidents behind bars and as
far as Rod Rosenstein Trump appointed
Rosenstein Trump has opted not to fire
Rosenstein Trump believes that his own
Deputy Attorney General who he hired and
has not fired should be put on trial for
committing treason against the United
States of America this is authoritarian
behavior this is really stupid behavior
this is embarrassing behavior on a
national stage but it's also
extraordinarily dangerous behavior from
the leader of a supposedly Western and
democratic country these I will remind
you are the types of pictures that were
on the side of that van that the mag a
bomber owned who sent pipe bombs in the
mail to a dozen Democrats and now Donald
Trump is retweeting almost identical
images to what that guy had taped or
pasted or superglued whatever it was to
the side of his van are you now ready to
tell me that I was correct when I said
that anyone who is still supporting
Donald Trump is either a bad person or
cognitively challenged and thus unable
to understand what's going on or merely
ignorant of the facts can we now save
that and for everybody who I know is
gonna write to me and say David this is
a joke Pat can't you explain to David
that this is what is is it's a it's
satire it's
the joke that's wrong the president on
one hand is tweeting pictures of his
political enemies in jail but he's also
taking action wanting to direct the
Justice Department to prosecute his
political enemies remember we learned
over the weekend that he was going to
direct the Justice Department to
prosecute James Comey and Hillary
Clinton until his attorney Don Magan
told him you might not want to do that
you could end up getting impeached for
that so Pat for everybody who I know is
going to write in to us and comment
online and say these are jokes number
one are these jokes becoming of the
office of the presidency of the United
States and number two we know it's not a
joke
we know Trump talks about the
prosecution of his political enemies
behind the scenes in a serious manner I
really wonder how Sarah Huckabee Sanders
is going to explain this one away like
will she say that Trump's retweets are
not endorsements or that the sentiments
behind the art is what actually is true
like that this Russia investigation is
all hysterical nonsense and that people
like Robert Muller and Hillary Clinton
all have to be investigated yeah it'll
probably be a combination of that with
with pointing out that he didn't tweet
it he retweeted it and the fake news
media is saying that he tweeted it even
though it was a retweet which of course
at this point is more or less a
distinction without a difference that or
a difference without a distinction or
apply whatever phrase you want to it and
and actually the the Sarah Huckabee
Sanders reaction is part of what I'm
going to watch but also what are
Republicans going to do what are
Republicans going to say because every
Republican elected official who doesn't
act to put a stop to this is now part of
the problem every Republican and
Democrat by the way although Democrats
don't really have the power at this
point to do much about it every
Republican who doesn't work to put a
stop to this is part of the problem they
are part of allowing the office of the
presidency to be weaponized into a
threat to the democracy that we hold as
an important element of the United
States of America the only hope that I
have
is that Trump is acting even more
erratic because he sees and he infers
and he knows that the walls are closing
in on him that the molar probe and
Democrats taking over investigations
when they are sworn in and take control
of the house that Michael Cohen now
pleading guilty and directly
contradicting Trump's claims that he was
not aware of her involved in any
dealings with Russia Michael Cohen
pleading guilty today and saying I was
keeping Trump personally informed about
Trump Tower Moscow and that project that
he realizes that he had better be scared
and that that's where the erratic
behavior is coming from that's the only
possible upside and the men afford
disaster that that exists could be about
to reveal untold criminality by Trump
and Trump might just be on tilt we're
going to see soon but this is
embarrassing behavior Trump arriving
tonight in Argentina my home country for
all sorts of meetings as part of the g20
it's embarrassing it's embarrassing for
him to be the representative of the
United States
among leaders who we may agree with or
disagree with politically but who other
than the authoritarian ones that Trump
seems to like don't hold a free press in
contempt
don't debase the politics of the nation
through retweets of political memes like
these it is a disgusting embarrassment
that this is the guy representing us
around the world today's program was
made possible in part by Blink esteem /
Pakman I love bling cast it's the really
perfect app for anybody who likes
politics and learning and if you're
watching or listening to the David
Pakman show
I'm sure you love politics and learning
and what blinka studs is take the best
and most popular non-fiction books they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to in one sitting
and you can learn about politics
philosophy psychology economics often we
don't have the time to actually read as
many books as we would like I know that
I'm at my limit for how much I can read
and this way you can absorb the most in
horton valuable information from books
in just 15 minutes
maybe on your way to work maybe on your
way to the gym maybe cooking vegan
recipes at home whatever is your thing
and our audience can get a seven day
free trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube
I've put a link in the video description
and after the free trial if you like it
and I think you will
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for just about 5
bucks a month you can go to be li NK is
t.com slash PA k ma n to sign up